While members of superhero teams like
the Avengers and the Justice League
may save the world in spite of their flaws, when
it comes to the members of the Suicide Squad,
without their weaknesses, they wouldn't
even be part of the crew in the first place.
The biggest weakness of Weasel, played
in The Suicide Squad by Sean Gunn,
is his insatiable bloodthirst. In the source
material, the savage little beast man is part
of one of the most disastrous Task Force X
missions on record in terms of body count,
and Weasel is one of the main
reasons almost no one comes home.
In 1988's The Doom Patrol
and Suicide Squad Special #1,
Weasel is part of a Squad lineup sent to free
the superhero Hawk from a fortress in Nicaragua.
Rick Flag leads the Squad — which, along
with Weasel, includes Psi, Thinker,
and Mr. 104 — and he's also the only survivor.
Psi and Mr. 104 are both killed by the armored
Soviet soldiers of the Rocket Red Brigade,
while Weasel and Thinker kill each other.
When the Squad runs into members of Doom
Patrol — who are also there hoping to free
Hawk — things quickly get tense. Mr. 104, an
old enemy of Doom Patrol, attacks the heroes.
When Thinker tries to stop Mr. 104, Weasel
— not caring about 104's grudges but just
wanting to spill more blood – rips
Thinker's throat open, killing him.
Rick Flag takes Thinker's helmet from
the villain's corpse and uses its power,
but unbeknownst to Flag, the villain imprinted the
helmet with the final command to
get revenge on Thinker's killer.
Before Flag removes the helmet, it unleashes
a powerful blast, killing Weasel instantly.
As to the biggest weakness of John Cena's
Peacemaker, well, it's kind of in the name.
"Be like a douchey Captain America."
In spite of being on a team with the likes
of Harley Quinn, the gun-toting vigilante
suffers arguably the most singular mental
illness of any other member of Suicide Squad.
Traumatized by the suicide of his
father — a Nazi concentration camp
commander — Peacemaker has developed
the troubling philosophy that peace
is worth any cost, including killing
anyone he deecms an enemy of peace.
"The guy who believes in peace at any cost,
no matter how many people he
needs to kill along the way."
His illness goes so far as to make Peacemaker
believe the ghost of his father and the ghosts
of the long list of people he's killed speak
to him from inside his strange metal helmet.
Peacemaker's internal struggles are enough to make
you wonder why Amanda Waller or anyone else would
ever be willing to recruit him. He may be good
in a fight, but his mental illness is a glaring
liability. If an enemy knows what makes Peacemaker
tick and that he hears disembodied voices
he attributes to the dead, it won't take
much to manipulate the vigilante. After all,
if you believe the best road to peace is to
mow down everyone who disagrees with you,
imagine what other kinds of insanity
you could be made to believe?
Savant is a genius — and he knows it. While he
doesn't boast any kind of metahuman abilities,
his intellect and hand-to-hand fighting
skills make him a formidable opponent,
and he isn't shy about letting
you know how dangerous he can be.
Savant originally came on the scene
wanting to become the next Batman,
though he would eventually decide to
turn his efforts toward blackmail.
In the comics, Savant's time with the Suicide
Squad makes it clear his biggest vulnerability
is his arrogance. For example, Savant is a part
of the Squad lineup sent after Harley Quinn
when she goes rogue. After the team
tracks Harley to a police station,
Savant constantly butts heads with Deadshot
- almost coming to blows. When Deadshot urges
Savant to take Harley seriously as a threat,
saying "Savant, she's dangerous," Savant answers,
"I'm dangerous. She's just some psycho
looking for her dead boyfriend's face."
Once Savant goes one on one with Harley,
that arrogance nearly leads to his death.
Harley tricks Savant into charging into a
jail cell where she's hidden a pressure mine.
Savant is forced to stay there, standing on the
mine, to prevent the explosive from going off.
Harley locks him in the cell, and Deadshot
is forced to deal with Harley on his own.
King Shark is one of the most physically
powerful members of the Suicide Squad. He
can breathe underwater and swim as well as any
fish. He's a powerhouse with superhuman strength,
and he has absolutely no compunction about
not only killing, but eating anyone who
gets in his way. Unfortunately, as you might
guess, King Shark isn't the greatest thinker
of DC's characters and that can lead to
complications, for him as well as the Squad.
"Nanaue, play nice with your brother!"
True to his name, King Shark is usually thinking
with his stomach if he's thinking at all.
In 2011's Suicide Squad #2, for example,
as the team battles a stadium full of
grotesquely mutated humans, Deadshot has to
urge King Shark to keep moving because the
man-monster keeps stopping to eat his victims.
In the following issue, after Deadshot assures
his teammates that King Shark "knows to keep
a low profile," the action cuts to the aquatic
villain tearing through a farmer's chicken
coop and devouring the poor birds inside.
In the volume of Suicide Squad launched
in 2019, it's partly King Shark's lack
of intelligence that leads him to become
one of the earliest victims of the comic.
In the third issue of that series, King Shark
lets his guard down in the presence of his enemy,
Fin — an aquatic character whose brother
he killed and ate two issues earlier.
King Shark's thoughtlessness in the face of danger
comes back to bite him, literally. Fin rewards the
stupidity with poetic justice, summoning
a nearby school of sharks to devour him.
Alice Braga's Solsoria doesn't appear
in the Suicide Squad comics or any of
DC's publications, so it's tough to nail
down any weaknesses or strengths. However,
one popular theory suggests Solsoria
is a gender-bent version of Juan Soria.
If that's the case, then it doesn't bode well
for the future of this mystery character.
Juan Soria appears in Suicide Squad #33 and
#34. He's just a regular guy who dreams of
joining the Justice League, and when his
hand is injured in a workplace accident,
he uses the opportunity to inject nanites into his
body that give him the ability to open any lock.
He tries and fails to join the Justice League,
and shortly afterward turns to a life of crime.
After the inevitable arrest, Amanda
Waller recruits him into Task Force X,
though his metahuman ability has less to do with
her choice than his crippling low self-esteem.
She sends the Squad against a powerful
alien who ends up capturing Soria
and feeding off his energy. Amusingly,
Soria's self-critical negative feelings
cause the alien to shrink to the point
where he can kill it by stepping on it.
Juan Soria correctly assumes he's destined to die.
He becomes similar to Sam Rockwell's character
Guy Fleegman in the film Galaxy Quest,
assuming that because he's the new character
with no codename, he'll be the one to die.
"My character isn't important enough for a last
name, because I'm gonna die five minutes in."
"Guy, you have a last name."
"Do I?!"
In spite of surviving the battle
against the alien invader,
he's rewarded for his service by having
his nanite-enhanced hands removed,
after which it's revealed that he was Waller's
pawn in the plan the whole time. And then Waller
puts him in the same cell as Killer Croc, who —
it's strongly implied — uses Soria as a snack.
Peter Capaldi's the Thinker is one
of the oldest characters appearing
in The Suicide Squad. His criminal career
dates back to the Golden Age of comics,
and among other exploits he's one of the
founding members of the Injustice Society.
In the comics, the Thinker's abilities stem
from the so-called "Thinking Cap" he wears.
The cap gives Thinker access to
powerful psychic abilities such as
telepathy and telekinesis. Without the cap,
however, Thinker has no powers to speak of.
Even with the cap, physically the Thinker
isn't particularly formidable and he appears
to be the oldest member of Task Force X.
This is similar to Thinker's situation
in the comics. When he joins Task Force X in
1988's Doom Patrol and Suicide Squad Special,
he warns his teammates that he plans
to succeed in his mission and stop
anyone who gets in his way because he's
"growing old" and the pardon he's meant
to receive for his service is necessary
to live the rest of his life in peace.
But the Thinker doesn't survive long
enough to retire. When things go sideways,
his teammate Weasel kills him with a single
swipe of his claw. Thinker's biggest weakness,
then, is his physical vulnerability. His psychic
powers make it difficult to get to him, but if
somehow you manage to reach him as Weasel does,
then it doesn't take much to incapacitate him.
As the head of Task Force X, Amanda Waller
(a.k.a. "The Wall") spends most of her time
behind the scenes, monitoring the team and
making sure they do what they're supposed to do.
When the explosives in one of the recruits'
necks goes off, there's a pretty good chance
it's Waller giving the order to detonate.
Waller is just as ruthless as the worst
villains she brings into Task Force X, and can be
just as cold-blooded. She has absolutely no moral
qualms about feeding any of her recruits into the
meat grinder, including ordering their deaths.
The challenge Waller tends to face in
every incarnation of the Suicide Squad
is that while she may be the top
dog when it comes to Task Force X,
she's part of a government bureaucracy that will
only allow her to go so far outside the box.
The original Suicide Squad run, for example,
includes storylines in which rival politicians
target Waller, using their knowledge of
the Suicide Squad's actions as leverage.
As much as she may want it to be, Waller's
rule over the Suicide Squad is not absolute.
She's reminded of this in 2019's Suicide
Squad #1, when the new volume opens with
the control of Task Force X being taken
from her by the even more coldhearted Lok.
In The Suicide Squad, Flula Borg
will play the former Olympic athlete
Javelin. The crook carries a high-tech cache
of explosive spears and he's been both a member
of and enemy to the Suicide Squad a number of
times in the comics, including the 2005 volume
of Deadshot in which Javelin joins a team of
villains wanting revenge on the expert marksman.
Javelin's biggest weakness is fairly
obvious: With no metahuman abilities,
he's highly dependent on his gimmick weaponry.
As an athlete in peak physical condition,
his hand-to-hand combat skills
are nothing to sneeze at,
but without the weapons that make up
his namesake, Javelin won't last long.
Not to mention that even when he does have
his spears, they're not always a help.
Like just about any comic book supervillain who's
been around long enough, Javelin has been killed
a number of times only to be resurrected, and
more often that not it's been in part his own
spears that kill him. In Deadshot #5, for example,
the marksman kills Javelin by shooting one of his
explosive spears while it's still in his hand.
Years earlier in 1991's War of the Gods #3,
the sorceress Circe kills Javelin
by impaling him on his own spear.
There have been at least three different comic
book versions of Bloodsport, though in The Suicide
Squad Idris Elba is set to play the original
— Robert DuBois, who comes close to killing
Superman in 1987's Superman #4 after shooting
the Man of Steel with a sliver of kryptonite.
If Elba's portrayal of Bloodsport is anything like
the source material, his biggest weakness is bound
to be his mental illness, including guilt that
sits on his shoulders like a thousand-ton weight.
Bloodsport enters the world of comics in a bloody
rampage across Metropolis. Early in the story,
you get the impression he's a disgruntled veteran
of the Vietnam War. He guns down random civilians,
all the while proclaiming that
they're wasting the freedoms he
and others fought for. Eventually, we learn
Bloodsport didn't fight for anyone's freedoms.
It's Superman's pal and Daily
Planet photojournalist Jimmy Olsen
who discovers that Robert DuBois never served in
the military. Instead, he fled to Canada and his
younger brother Mickey took his place. Mickey
lost both of his arms and legs in the conflict,
and it's Robert DuBois' guilt over his
brother's injuries that drive him to madness.
Superman #4 ends with Olsen finding Mickey and
bringing him to the still-rampaging Bloodsport,
who collapses in tears at the
sight of his younger brother.
If Elba's Bloodsport carries
a similarly guilty conscience,
being reminded of his mistakes could do
more damage to him than a Kryptonian's fist.
Comedian Pete Davidson plays
Blackguard in The Suicide Squad,
and his biggest weakness is, well...
he doesn't really have any strengths.
"I'm afraid to say you have died."
"Okay."
Okay, so maybe that's not completely true.
Blackguard's real name is Richard Hertz and
he was a common criminal before being recruited
by the powerful Metropolis organization the 1000.
He wears armor capable of generating
an energy mace and energy shield;
beyond that, he doesn't have a whole lot to
offer. He isn't particularly bright and while
his armor would make him a huge threat
to just about anyone in the real world,
in the world of superheroes and
villains, it doesn't mean a whole lot.
Predictably, Blackguard doesn't survive
his stay with the Suicide Squad. When
the super strong General Wade Eiling turns
on his teammates in 2008's Suicide Squad
#7, Blackguard is his first victim — and it
doesn't take much of an effort to kill him.
Eiling grabs Blackguard and rips his head off
before the latter even knows what's happening.
Digger Harkness, a.k.a. Captain Boomerang,
first showed up in 1960's The Flash #117,
kicking off a long career of being a
pain in the Scarlet Speedster's neck.
Along with being played by Jai
Courtney on the big screen,
Captain Boomerang has been a mainstay
in the Suicide Squad comics for years.
While portrayals change as writers and artists
come and go, a regular hallmark of Captain
Boomerang is also his biggest weakness as far as
Task Force X is concerned — he's arguably the most
consistently treacherous member of the Suicide
Squad, and it never seems to end well for him.
"You're free to go."
Hating Amanda Waller more than just about anyone
— a tall order in Task Force X — there isn't much
Captain Boomerang won't do to escape his service,
to pull one over on Waller, or just to annoy her.
He's let teammates die when he could have
easily saved them, he's tricked teammates
into killing themselves, and in the case of the
young Hack, he flat-out murdered a colleague.
He's also disguised himself as other
supervillains to continue making money
while working for the Suicide Squad, and
has pulled elaborate pranks on the entire
team. His efforts have resulted in —
among other things — the thief having
what little privileges he enjoyed revoked
by Amanda Waller, and in at least one case
had him unceremoniously dropped from a
helicopter and stranded on a deserted island.
Rick Flag's biggest weakness
is that the Suicide Squad is
the last place he should be for his sanity.
On one hand there are the villains
and vigilantes recruited to the Squad,
on the other there's the Machiavellian
Amanda Waller, and between them is Joel
Kinnaman's Rick Flag — a soldier who wants
nothing more than to serve his country.
His place in the hierarchy, the things he's
forced to do as a member of the Suicide Squad,
and his values as a soldier all combine to make
Flag the unluckiest person in Task Force X.
"Theyre psychotic, antisocial
freaks. It makes no sense."
Flag would rather not be tied to career
criminals for his military service.
During his time in both the comics and
the movies, Flag has worked with killers,
thieves, and worse. He's literally commanded
cannibals as part of his duties. It forces
him to not only overlook pasts that many would
say shouldn't be overlooked, but often to turn
a blind eye to the ugly crimes the recruits
commit in the present for Flag and the Squad.
But for better or worse, they are his
recruits, and as a soldier Flag can't help
but feel responsible for them. Not to mention
that Amanda Waller doesn't share his feelings
of responsibility, and will readily sacrifice
any member of the Squad without losing a wink
of sleep over it, and when the smoke clears,
he'll have to continue taking orders from her.
Mayling Ng's Mongal is the daughter
of Mongul, an interstellar warlord
who's fought the likes of Superman to a
standstill. Depending on who you talk to,
Mongal's greatest weakness is either
her lust for battle or her family.
Like her father and brother, Mongal is blessed
with superhuman strength and resilience.
Also like the rest of her family, Mongal revels
in battle, and that could prove her undoing in The
Suicide Squad. If Ng's version of the character
is anywhere near as powerful as the one from the
source material, she'll be more than happy to
charge into any battlefield without thinking
twice, and if the Squad comes up against tough
enough adversaries, that could get her killed.
If it should happen that Mongal's family
somehow makes an appearance in the film,
that could prove the key to her destruction.
Her brother, Mongul the Younger, kills Mongal
in 2006's Green Lantern #8. Seeing a picture
of his father together with daughter and son,
Mongul the Younger proclaims that family
is a weakness. Unwilling to tolerate it,
Mongul decapitates his sister with a
single punch before she can respond.
Nathan Fillion will be playing a
character named TDK in The Suicide Squad,
though to diehard comics fans TDK is better
known by the hilarious name Arm-Fall-Off-Boy.
The character premieres in 1989's Secret Origins
#46 when he tries and fails to join the Legion
of Super-Heroes. TDK boasts the ability
to detach his arms and legs from his body
and use them as blunt instruments. You
may have often heard people in movies
and TV shows threaten to tear someone's
arm off and beat them with it — well,
TDK is somewhat kinder. He tears his
own arm off and beats you with it.
TDK's biggest weakness is pretty glaring. His
power, while hilarious, is pretty ridiculous.
If all he's doing is trying to surprise a friend
or get his buddies sick during a dinner party,
sure, he's golden. But in an actual
battle, he's kind of limited.
As soon as he tears off one arm, well, that's
it. He can only tear off the one arm because he
doesn't have anything to tear the second arm off
with, and nothing to swing it with regardless.
That leaves his legs, without which
he'll have difficulty standing,
walking, running, or even crawling.
So if he does remove one of his legs,
he better be aiming for his
opponent's shins, or what's the point?
Daniela Melchior is set to play
Ratcatcher 2 in The Suicide Squad.
We don't know much about how she differs
from the Otis Flannegan version of the
character beyond her gender, though
it seems likely — considering she's
actually referred to as Ratcatcher 2 in
the film's sneak preview trailer — that
the Flannegan version is meant to have existed
at some point before the events of the film.
If Ratcatcher 2 is anything like her predecessor,
then it's likely her biggest vulnerability
isn't tough to figure out. Flannegan is one of the
many villains to make Batman's life difficult in
Gotham City, and as Ratcatcher he's learned to
train and command whole armies of rats. In spite
of a pretty bizarre gimmick, his hordes of vermin
and his intimate knowledge of Gotham's sewer
system make Flannegan a formidable foe for Batman
or any other vigilante trying to spoil his plans.
But as far as we can tell, The Suicide Squad
isn't set in Gotham City. Which leaves Ratcatcher
2 possibly dependent on two things — an army of
rats and a knowledge of Gotham's sewers — that
will be of minimum help to her. Obviously, she's
going to be in the film for a reason, though it's
tough to imagine exactly how she's going to
transport armies of rats all over the place.
David Dastmalchian will play the Polka-Dot Man
in The Suicide Squad. Along with Condiment King
and Kite Man, Polka-Dot Man is one of those
corny Batman villains who doesn't really fit
in the kind of gritty, dark Batman stories
the general public is used to these days,
and usually only surfaces as part of a gag or a
parody like LEGO Batman. But now the bad guy who
looks like a Twister board is graduating to the
live-action big leagues with the Suicide Squad.
Without knowing how this version
of Polka-Dot Man will be portrayed,
just judging by the fact that he's
named Polka-Dot Man makes us suspect
his biggest weakness will be the challenge
of being taken seriously by his comrades.
Polka-Dot Man is pretty low on the pecking order
of Gotham City's long list of bad guys, and he
knows it better than anyone else. It's likely
he's going to feel like he has a lot to prove.
On the other hand, it's easy to imagine
Polka-Dot Man's biggest weakness could
also be one of his greatest strengths.
Think about it — if you were attacked
by a villain calling himself Polka-Dot Man,
how long would it take you to stop laughing,
and how much damage could he do to you while
you were busy not taking him seriously?
Surprising no one, Margot Robbie will reprise
her role as Harley Quinn in The Suicide Squad.
Thanks to the events of 2020's Birds
of Prey, the weakness that would have
been assigned to her a few years
ago isn't in the picture anymore.
Most fans would likely agree that it wasn't
that long ago that Harley's biggest weakness
had one name — Joker. In both the animated
series that first brought Harley to life,
and in the comics that followed, Harley couldn't
resist the Joker. No matter how many times he hurt
her, no matter how many times he betrayed her,
Harley would always welcome her "puddin'" back
with open arms. But after the events of Birds
of Prey, Harley's learned to be independent,
and we don't think she'd even be tempted
to take Joker back if he returned.
No, instead Harley's biggest vulnerability is also
perhaps her greatest strength, and arguably the
main reason she's of any use to the Suicide Squad.
Harley has no fear. In spite of having no special
metahuman abilities to call her own, Harley would
wade into a hail of bullets if she thought it was
a fun thing to do, and she'd do it laughing.
It's part of what makes her so dangerous,
though it could ultimately send her to that
creepy, abandoned amusement park in the sky.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.